you need to change how you walk you are
walking wrong just Janet destroyed one
of my shoes she destroyed a pair of my
shoes puppies like to eat their shoes I
got distracted where was I
what's up elimination I used to have
really bad back and knee problems in my
20s I got rid of them I'm gonna share
with you the five ways I did it without
exercising and hopefully gives you guys
some relief as well
[Music]
so when my 20s I used to have really bad
knees and back problems I'd be going to
a chiropractor every week getting
adjustments doing stretches I had to get
custom orthotics multiple times with
different machines nothing seemed to
work and I was frustrated like I'm in my
20s why am I having such bad knee and
back problems I got rid of the problems
by Justin how it worked I'm gonna share
with you my hacks today hack number one
is use a stand-up desk this changed my
life now standing up has been a lot more
popular recently I started doing this
over a decade ago it dramatically
changed my life this is my setup right
now huh what do think chemo I know so
this is my setup right now this desk
actually could just buy from Ikea I want
to say it's a couple hundred dollars I
don't remember exactly what I spent on
it but it's not expensive what I love
about this is it's just a-- below
there's a little remote control it plugs
into the wall you can you can move it up
and down if you like to the adjustment
that you want you can also do in the
stain setup desk we have another one
that also is adjustable you can get this
one at IKEA - but it's not electric so
you have to just uh position it can I
see something in the back you can kind
of see it a little bit there at the back
but this one is cheaper but it's a
manual adjustment and the one that I
have in here is electric automatic so a
lot easier to move up and down what you
want to do is get it to the height we
feel comfortable with so I'm always go
for convenience alright so I love it now
getting used to a stand-up desk is
difficult and you can't just stand up
all day long so don't get frustrated I
actually started here's the thing I hate
spending money before I make you money
and I love testing stuff out to make
sure it's gonna work for me so what I
did is I have this bookcase and when I
first started using a stand-up desk I
tested on this bookcase before going to
investing money to a desk even though
it's only that desk is like I don't know
400 bucks 500 bucks went out there is
like 200 bucks even though it's not a
lot of money I still
just like testing it I hate spending
money until it's something that's
working for me so I'm testing it on this
bookcase and I adjusted it
I forget what shelf level it was I use a
laptop and I test just standing up and I
can do it I don't think I did it for
like an hour the first day and then an
hour the second day and then by the end
of the week I was doing the two or three
hours and then by the next week I can
get to like three four hours and so I
built up my endurance so that I wasn't
getting tired standing up and it
dramatically shifted my lower back
I've had a lot less lower back pain
because I was standing up straight
because my posture when I'm sitting down
socks I'm doing that all day long really
messed up my lower back
and so just standing up straight all day
long made a massive massive massive
massive massive massive massive
difference for me pack number two is go
barefoot this is the thing that saved my
knees I am barefoot pretty much all day
long so when I am at home I'm barefoot
winning my TDs I'm new to barefoot and
if I'm out I usually wear barefoot shoes
so I started with the Vibram Five toe
shoes again I think they're picking up
in popularity but as soon as I learned
about them I I had to try them out I had
to try them out because my knees were
this just completely unlimited going
barefoot completely eliminated although
I need pains
although the expensive custom orthotics
all the trips to see the doctors this is
the thing that saved my life and so
these are the Vibram Five toed shoes
I am NOT an investor or get paid to do
this but these are I've been wearing
these or versions of this for the past I
don't know it might be a decade I don't
know whenever vibrant first came out
they've gone through multiple
generations I wear them the business
trips I wear them I conferences I wear
them to speaking gigs it's great you
know the other thing is they have a new
version of it with a wrap so this is
pretty cool I mean let me show you how
this one works so you got a wrap
you put your foot in and then you wrap
one side and then you wrap the other
side and it basically fits to the exact
specifications of your foot you just got
to figure out how long your foot is but
then the tightness and the width you get
to pick I don't really have wide feet
but if you have wider feet you get the
kind of pick the comfort level for you
and so whenever I'm out every time I'm
out if I'm going any distance I'm using
my five toe shoes my Vibrams actually
here's a great story this girl here
sunbathing just Ana just Janet destroyed
one of my shoes she destroyed a pair of
my shoes puppies like to eat their shoes
she destroyed a pair of my shoes my
Vibrams the ones that I loved was in a
war everywhere and so I went to sandals
for a week look these these sandals
adidas sandals normal sandals woman for
a week my knees started hurting my knees
started hurting my back started hurting
like I need to get some new Vibrams and
so I went off and I got those too so I
would experiment testing with it going
barefoot again and just like setting up
this is not an easy thing to do because
your feet are used to shoes your feet
are used to thick soles your feet are
used to having the arch support it's
actually bad for you or at least for me
it was bad for me it going barefoot and
using barefoot shoes weathers Vibram
sure there's other companies as well it
changes how you walk because most people
what you do is you heel strike you sell
them and can I show you the heel
strength here Melissa how most people
walk you go heel toe heel toe heel toe
that's how you walk that's how most
people walk is you got these really
thick cushioning heels and your shoes
and that allows you to walk like that
but it's actually at least for me is not
good for your body was not good for my
was not good for my back when you tried
to heal strike when you try to walk like
that heel-toe heel-toe when you're
barefoot or in barefoot shoes it hurts
it hurts your heel because there's no
support there anymore and most people
when they first tried to say well that's
bad I'm not getting an arch support heel
support I need to go back to my running
shoes no no you need to change how you
walk you're walking wrong your shoes are
making you walk run barefoot is how
you're supposed to walk right that's how
you were born is how you are supposed to
walk and so again this takes time when
you get a barefoot shoes or if you're
going barefoot throughout the house or
at home or the office even when I have
my office and even at EDS I'll still go
barefoot it takes time to get used to
just like using a stand-up desk like
that you'll use use the bookcase before
you use the stand-up desk
test test test ssssss s so you might
only be able to go for 30 minutes walk
and then your heels start getting tired
and then slowly you'll adjust and you'll
adjust Mila just not under the whole day
setting it up and hold a barefoot 2-pack
number three have your arms just over 90
degrees at your desk so so here's what
most people do so most people sit down
they sit down you're here right you're
sitting first of all you're like
massively slumped we're working like
this over a laptop or a computer like
can I can I shave my back that really my
arms not long enough look at that arch
that's how most people do it right well
I've made my life work on the laptop
okay most tables are too tall most
chairs are too short and so your arms
end up being like this this is not good
and especially if it's a little bit
raised because you have a keyboard or a
laptop if you're working like this this
is not good see that bend that's not
good what you want to have is just over
90 degrees and so when you're setting up
your desk even if you don't do a
stand-up desk where I want you to go if
you want to save your back but even if
you don't do a stand-up desk which you
want at your desk is your arms to be
just over 90 degrees so I'm standing
here at my desk standing here look at my
arm this would be 90 like resting flat
and I'm about here
so what you want to do is adjust where
you're standing or adjust the height of
your desk that's why I love this one and
again like it's a it's a couple hundred
bucks but it's a four hundred bucks from
Ikea I've never had to go off and buy
more expensive desk because it suits my
purposes so what they use that stand up
desk are you using a typical desk like
this you know adjust it so that between
the seat and the desk your arms are just
over 90 degrees when you're working at
your keyboard pack number four make your
monitor height higher a lot of you your
monitors are too low it's causing neck
pain is causing hunched no but you're
doing this because you want to get
closer to the monitor closer to the
screen it's bad for you solution bring
the monitor up this is especially bad
when you have laptops because the mother
is so low and if you're hunched over a
laptop for too long you're gonna feel
the pain in your back and also in your
neck so what I do that's my setup I
actually just use my books this is
another another quick hack just
experiment and test right and I haven't
got out and invest in anything greater
because I just used some copies of my
own book your one word now I've
experimented with it and you can see
what is actually this one is higher than
this one this is where I want to be this
is where I was and this is not where I
wanna be what you want is the monitor to
be just around here like this height
level around this head level but still
of distance right you could be through
coming in like this or like we usually
we are in the laptops you're gonna get I
use it's too close you're gonna mess up
your eye so you have to be a little bit
further away and the monitor height
should be just around here so you're
looking down a little bit down the angle
so this is what it ends up looking like
for me I've got my keyboard I've got my
keyboard here right 90 degree arms and
then for me I need however my books that
is to get to the monitor I perfect
height for me now I got to add some more
books to this side
make it match and hack number five this
is a new one that I've been doing for
the past year or so I'm really bad at
looking back so I'm not exactly sure how
long but it's use a rebounder rebounder
is a mini trampoline there's Teemo
that's the one I don't know downside
upside abuse and a trampoline rebounder
if you've got animals they might like to
be on there with you so I am working and
I've got this guy here with me why do I
use it I think I got inspired by Tony
Robbins who he likes to bounce on a
rebounder before he goes on stage I
don't know anybody who's standing on a
rebounder all day long I like it one
because it just makes me move already
when you're on a stand-up desk you are
moving throughout the day like you're
moving you're not you're not marched on
the spot but your lower body is
activated where when you're sitting down
your lower body just kind of shuts off
but with the rebounder you're moving a
little bit I just find myself throughout
the day bouncing I'm bouncing a little
bit just working and I find that it
helps get my body moving a little bit
it's not like a huge cardio workout but
it's way better than sitting down and I
find it better than standing the other
thing I love about it is it's just a
little more cushiony it's a little more
support versus a hard floor or even a
rug I like that I can kind of sink in on
it a little bit and so I'm a fan and
luckily luckily what do you want Teemo
Yuma wants to say hi are you sick of the
rebounder you sick of the rebounder you
just want to say hi hello believe nation
will go back on the trampoline yeah
I got distracted where was I yes
so rebounder the downside of it as well
as when I'm doing interviews you can see
my camera setup there when I'm doing
interviews I have to make sure that I
stand really still because I naturally
just want to bounce but you don't want
to see this on the other side of the
camera so I have to focus on staying
still but I'm a big fan highly recommend
checking it out
I bought that rebounder at Walmart I
want to say it's like 70 bucks 50 bucks
I don't remember and again haven't
really found the need to upgrade because
it's just my purposes so all of this
stuff is pretty cheap pretty easy to do
don't spend a lot of money on it always
test always hack your way right use the
bookcase before you invest go barefoot
and try it before you go and buy the
shoes so those are the five hacks that
really helped save my back and knees I'd
love to know if you have a hack 6 7 or 8
that you want to add to the list let me
know that little comments below if you
liked this video and you want to learn
how to use your cell phone so that you
don't get neck pain check out the video
right next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy continue to believe and I'll see
you there
no no that's what you're doing right you
got to do it wrong then I thought that's
kind of weird to have an Indian woman on
my background